when i think back to the person i was
when i thought i didn't want to have
kids it was all based on this
misunderstanding it was based on this
false idea that you have to be boring
especially as a woman if you're going to
be the ones having the kids and doing it
right
then you had just better get ready to be
boring for like two decades out of your
life and i can't sign up for that i
don't like i'll die i mean that my my
brain will melt i just
maybe this is even a bad thing maybe
it's something i need to go to therapy
for but it is what it is
i can't have a boring life and
i almost missed out on
this incredible life like i'm so
grateful for my kids for my family i
love my life
so much i i can't even put it into words
and to think that i almost missed out on
it based on the misunderstanding that
you have to be boring if you're a mother
i swear my life's work like if i
convince one person that you can be
interesting and you can have kids even a
lot of kids if that's the right path for
you
then i will feel like
everything i have done
is worth it every sacrifice every
rejection every difficult thing i've
gone through in my career
it is worth it if i put forth into the
world
a new
model of what motherhood can look like
[Music]
welcome to episode 145 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
currently with allergies
hence
my voice
they were so bad last week i didn't
release an episode because i had no
voice
so this might just be what i sound like
now anyway this is your new podcast host
this was an in-person podcast soon they
will all be in person how exciting my
guest today is stand up comic jen
fullwhiler the author of three books it
was fun i don't have as many women on my
podcast for some reason but i really
like jen a disagreeable super
conscientious mother of six kids
we discussed making sacrifices for
children how she funded her first comedy
to her by herself
different personality types thrill
seeking behavior improvement negotiating
a shared vision of your life with your
partner and more
her tour is currently on sale if you're
interested in seeing her live
this episode was brought to you by
rabbit air
i had serious issues getting quality
sleep i kept waking up in the middle of
the night but kept writing it off as
just stress
it was stress but it turns out it was
more than just stress i was also
allergic to the air in my room because
i'm a bubble person hence my allergy
ridden voice at the moment
anyway i bought an air purifier and it
changed my sleep increasing the deep
sleep portion
rabbit air has a whole line of beautiful
whisper quiet air purifiers that use
advanced filtration technology to
capture airborne allergens particles and
annoying smells check them out i have
them in almost every room including
right back here that guy
including this room
you can customize them like you just saw
so they don't look dorky although mine
might still look dorky but i like it so
don't insult it their bio gs 2.0 model
has been called the mercedes of air
purifiers and it won the world's most
prestigious red dot design award
google image it bio gs 2.0 anyway these
things absolutely transform the way i
sleep and are currently saving me from
horrifying tree allergies that i'm still
suffering from but i mean i could be
just dead
i could be dead i might be without these
air purifiers
uh so i have a lion on mine if you guys
want to copy that or make fun of it do
whatever you want
if you ever run into a problem with
these guys their 24 7 support team super
friendly and helpful do yourself a favor
try them out you won't regret it visit
rabbitair.com and take advantage of
their five-year warranty free shipping
and returns and a 90-day money-back
guarantee on their products that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r
some of the best air purifiers you'll
find in the market again only at
rabbitair.com
enjoy this episode
[Music]
jen fullweiler welcome to my podcast i
am so excited to be here i love your
podcasts
you look great thank you thank you i've
got my makeup routine down to where i
can do tv or video podcast makeup this
is a 20 minute look when you have six
kids you figure these things out quickly
mine's mine's down to about six minutes
nice we look amazing so we need to trade
tips
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do yes um i well what
stands out to people about me is i have
six kids i had six babies in eight years
no twins
i am a uh i'm a stand-up comedian uh the
jokes write themselves when that is your
lifestyle and uh when i first got into
stand-up comedy because because i have
six kids i wasn't able to
spend as much time in comedy clubs as a
lot of other comedians because that i
just i just couldn't i mean i did i went
to clubs quite a bit but
not as much as other people could so i
had trouble getting booked for a tour
and uh so my best friend and i uh booked
our own they we booked a tour for me
just using my personal credit card so i
went out and i did that tour and most of
the events sold out it was incredible
and that really kind of
launched my stand-up comedy career we
filmed a special as part of that and so
that was really what what kind of
got momentum behind my comedy career
okay so that must have been a little bit
stressful trying like don't you have to
put up quite a bit of money up front in
order to book those venues yeah i mean
i'll just tell you some numbers like so
here's the other thing i had to rent the
theaters
on
like monday tuesday wednesday nights
because they're half price if you do off
nights and so i could get them for maybe
four or five thousand
flat fee but then i would also have to
pay like their fees for ushers and all
these other fees but you have to pay in
advance and there are no refunds and i'd
never done a tour like this and so
i was on the hook for all of this money
i mean we had the first round we ended
up doing about 15 cities but the first
round was like eight cities and one of
them was expensive it's 10k it all went
on the credit card and i had to pay all
that whether or not i sold tickets and i
will tell you i have never
been so terrified in my life as the
night before i put tickets on sale
because i was like that there's no plan
b there's no backup plan
if these tickets don't sell like i don't
know what i'll do
did you have a social media following
like
so you could kind of gauge like maybe
this percentage of my audience is gonna
buy tickets and did you knew where your
audience was or how did that work yes
and what what i had based that on is the
previous year i did a book tour i had a
book that came out and so i had gone
around to meet fans and i got a pretty
good response now that was just for a
book tour so i had now do my fans about
stand-up comedy i know
but um so i was i did have some reason
to believe that people might maybe show
up if i did a tour and that was what i
was was betting on
okay book tour i've always been curious
so for a book tour is it just you
standing there signing books or like an
hour and a half of talking about your
book
that is a great question uh that is so i
didn't figure that question out until
after i booked my bookstore i was like
okay now i've charged people to show up
so what will i be doing and what i
decided that's it was one of the ways i
sort of worked out my stand-up comedy i
gave a speech
related to the book but i made it i it
was essentially stand up it was but it
was on the topic of the book and so
that's what i did that's what people
were getting for their money and then i
would stay and just hang out with fans
afterwards and so that's kind of what
they got is a meet and greet and then uh
speech which was really stand-up comedy
from me
okay and you've got so you you do
stand-up comedy but you have a number of
books right i do i have three books yeah
and some of them were fairly popular i
think yeah i mean i got on the wall
street journal bestseller list didn't
quite hit the new york times and uh like
number one uh seller at barnes noble so
yeah they did they did pretty well and
what's interesting is i i always thought
i would be a writer i thought that was
my thing it is how i defined myself it
earlier in my career it really didn't
occur to me that i would do anything
else and so it's always kind of funny to
me that when people meet me now
sometimes people don't even know i'm a
writer i'm like
not no i'm a writer you know it's a big
shift yeah that's cool yeah
okay so i wanted to bring you on because
i think i saw i saw something on your
instagram a long time ago that was
something about modern moms like be a
traditional mom and then yeah this
little skit about being a traditional
mom which we can probably throw up on
the podcast yeah you can get an idea of
what it is
ladies be good mothers this summer and
spend time with your children the
traditional way which doesn't involve
any of this because traditional mothers
were busy for most of human history
survival was a mom's full-time job if
your kids wanted chicken nuggets it was
up to you to take it from chicken to
nugget without refrigeration food had to
be cooked daily without indoor plumbing
getting water was a whole ordeal the
laundry spin cycle was your bare hands
and without electricity this all had to
be done during daylight hours there is
no historical precedent for moms being
the primary entertainers of their kids
they never had time meaningful moments
with their children happen but it was in
the midst of their business or in the
evenings maybe traditional moms pinned
clothes on clotheslines and you pin
clothes on pinterest either way it's
natural and normal for a woman to have a
lot of her daily focus on something
other than entertaining her kids hug
your kids love your kids tell your kids
you're thrilled to be doing life with
them and then unapologetically make time
for your own adult work because that is
what traditional motherhood looks like
but i just want to talk to you a bit
about just how you managed to first of
all you said six kids in eight years
yeah
that's that's crazy
and that was so did you stay home how
did you manage to do the writing at the
same time or was like for a period of
time were you just like just overrun
with children or yeah no i i did i
stayed home um i mean we just couldn't
afford full-time child care for that
number of kids you do end up in a
financial situation where it's like one
of us is staying home because you get
you know to get to get full-time child
care for that number of little kids it's
like a teacher oh yes daycare yeah yeah
it's it's no joke and so i did stay home
and um but
i wrote
those books while i was staying home
with those
kids at that time with a bunch of little
kids and people would ask
how do you do it like i mean how why
would you add more stress to your plate
to have these book deadlines and and i
got a pretty big deal with harper
collins for my second third books and
that involved deadlines and pressure
but what i always tell people is when
you find that thing
that you are called to do a friend of
mine calls it your blue flame when you
find that blue flame work that you're
meant to do
not only does it not feel like work but
it gives you energy i had more energy to
be a mom to i had three kids in diapers
for mo the better part of a decade three
kids in diapers at once because i have a
baby as soon as you know the older one
got out of diapers and so it you know
kids don't sleep through the night i
mean it was
it was very difficult physically but
what got me through it was doing that
writing having to do a chapter i have to
having to have that fin that chapter
finished by friday it made me
get up a little earlier in the morning
it made me keep the kids on a schedule
so i could have that nap time to do my
writing
and i i really believe that it i was a
better mom for the fact that i had those
writing deadlines during that time
okay okay that's interesting so i think
one of the things i struggled with when
i had scarlet
was
my mom was a stay-at-home mom
so it's just my brother and i but she
stayed at home until i think we were in
grade seven and then she became a
massage therapist went to massage school
like full time but i had
i think what happened to me was i was in
university i had scarlet and then i
stayed home
for a period of time like when she was
really really little and
i didn't
i felt guilty doing anything that didn't
have that seemed like it didn't have
anything to do with her so at that point
it was just like any type of writing or
like blog stuff i think i was just
writing a blog at that point or working
for my dad i was like
and i think it was partly
some people around me who are like
oh you should be only staying at home
and then there were the other people who
were like
you're wasting your life because you're
only staying at home but how do you like
do you have
suggestions
or
anything for i guess mothers
who are trying to figure out how much
time they should be spending on
themselves when they have little kids
yeah and that's what you know you
mentioned that sketch i did about
traditional mothers and that was exactly
the point that i was making in that
sketch um so
to give you a little bit of background
to lead into my answer to what you just
asked so i had the benefit of uh i guess
it was about 15 years ago at this point
i interviewed some relatives of mine who
were born in around like 1910 1912 and
they were
in their late 90s at the time and i just
asked them about life i didn't even know
what i was getting at but we just we did
some video we set up the old heavy
camcorder and videoed this
and at the time i had just had a baby
and so i didn't
intend for these to be interviews about
motherhood but i was so stressed out
because my kid didn't sleep through the
night and and i just was really maxed
out about it so that's just where my
mind went and i ended up asking my
grandfather and then his his cousin and
some of these other people i talked to i
parenthood just kept coming up and one
of the things that was very clear to me
and keep in mind these people you know
they were in their 20s in the 1920s and
30s so they knew people as adults who
lived in the 1800s i mean they were
really connected to an old old way of
life
and one of the things they emphasized is
how busy mothers were i mean when you
think about it i've been joking about
this on my podcast if your kids wanted
chicken nuggets
any time before like the past 50 years
it was up to you to take it from chicken
to nugget that was all on you and think
about how time-consuming that is you're
slaughtering animals you're doing all
that stuff to dress them you're chopping
it up i mean this to just get dinner on
the table was an hours long process and
so when you look at the history
of humanity when you look at human
evolution it simply could not be the
case that human children have evolved to
need their mother's attention for all or
even 90 or even 80 of her waking hours
because the work of survival was very
very time consuming for our female
ancestors
and that's the principle that i've
always used in my home of course your
kids need to be your priority and they
they need your attention and they need
focused attention but this is not
all day every day it couldn't be because
that's what i said in that in that
sketch that you saw traditional mothers
were busy and so if you are busy doing
your you're writing a book that's
similar to your ancestors who were busy
going slaughtering animals like getting
them ready for cooking yeah the work
you're doing is different but the time
commitment is about the same
okay that's interesting i guess some
people i think i think this was an
incorrect way of the way i was thinking
about it but it was because it didn't
have anything to do you know it was work
but it wasn't work for the kids so if
you're like trying to survive and
chopping wood and slaughtering chickens
then it's like okay that's directly for
the family but
i i know i certainly felt better when i
had time put aside for work because i'm
like i'm very you know work oriented
fulfills me you find a project to work
on and it's great right
so
it was tricky though i definitely had a
hard time
being like no
even though i'm doing something that
isn't related to that it's okay yeah i
was like deeply ingrained in me as the
wrong thing to do yep and i think we all
struggle with that that there yeah of
course there is a question of okay i
don't have to write this book the way my
great-grandmother had to
wash the clothes because everyone only
had three pairs of clothes but to me it
it seems like
i don't think it matters as much to your
children
what work you're doing i i think it just
feels natural that yeah mom has
stuff going on and for our ancestors
that might have been washing clothes out
on the washboard for us it might be
writing but i i don't think that it that
it matters to the children as long as
they know that
you that that they are your priorities
certainly there can be
cases if you know if someone were to
become obsessed with the work that
they're doing and they just neglect
their kids and they're they're not there
for their kids needs and they don't care
because all they care about is this work
that they're doing and certainly that
would be a problem and those things can
happen but i think um
i just
i never felt like it mattered that much
whether i was slaughtering chickens or
writing either way i i don't have time
to sit down for three hours in the
middle of the day and and only focus on
crafts or whatever and um
and it re and i also think that when we
compare ourselves like you did to
some of the women and i did this too uh
of course we all know the moms who were
like well i just i'm just focused on my
children so i i i do glitter
glitter crafts for five hours every day
is that you know home is my priority
well what i've noticed in my years of
watching parents is
these women are following their passions
too they have found that blue flame they
are doing things that energize and
inspire them too it just so happens that
their skills have more of a natural
translation to home life they're they're
the kind of women who
if they didn't have kids they might work
in a daycare or do that you work at a
kid's camp or something because they
have a natural affinity to working with
children and so
a lot of times i would say okay you guys
are getting unfair credit there you're
doing the same thing i am you're
following your passion you're doing
things that inspire you it just so
happens that what inspires you is
organizing the kitchen cabinets
perfectly and i couldn't care less about
my kitchen cabinets i'm doing writing
but we are both doing things that
energize and inspire us in a given day
i like that i like that okay
so i saw on your instagram stories a few
days ago i think you posted about your
parents and how you've been structuring
your comedy shows and you had a whole
bunch of spreadsheets up yes so i want
to get into that again because i was
like that is something i would do yeah
that's really cool
not a lot of people can relate to that
but i i knew it's funny i i figured that
that would resonate with you and i so
appreciate that because most people
think i'm crazy
and i and i'm so naive it comes so
naturally to do things like so i i put
my
whole stand-up comedy set in a
conditionally formatted google sheet and
the conditional formatting is when i put
in times between laughs and then the
different laugh level at the different
punch lines it automatically color codes
it that a laugh of three or above is red
a laugh at a two is orange a laugh at a
one or below is gray so i can see
visually when when i pull up my set i
can see the visual
of how it's doing and then the time
between laughs and it was great i could
scroll through it and say oh wait a
minute there is a lot of gray in this
area meaning time between laughs so i
thought okay i have some good jokes
there but this is showing me visually
that this is a weak part of my stand-up
comedy set and one of my friends was
just
speechless when i showed him this and he
said yeah that's just like richard pryor
used to do it and i am so naive i was
like d you know that makes so much sense
because he was so funny and
my friend started laughing like no jen i
was kidding no one's ever done this
you're insane
but my my dad was an engineer and um
my mom was actually like she calculated
kill ratios as a mathematician at the
naval weapons research laboratory so i
mean i'm hopeless like i just have that
mathematician engineer's brain
everything is spreadsheets everything in
life is quantifiable for me um so yeah
everything goes in a spreadsheet
including my stand-up comedy set but
what's interesting is um one of the
things that people in the comedy
industry talked about when i when i did
that tour
is they said okay so first of all you
booked it yourself and that's crazy but
they said how did you get a set so
quickly because that that all came about
very quickly and i pulled together my
set from having nothing to having a
pretty good set that was it's now a
special uh in i mean i think it came
together in five or six months which is
about half the time and again with six
kids i i couldn't spend every single
night down at the clubs because that
just would be impossible with six kids
but it was that quantification that i
would
have a friend come with me or my husband
and we'd video the set and i would have
to go back and watch that video which is
so painful you know full body video of
yourself and then you have to and you
know so of course sometimes i'd bomb
these people didn't know who i was and
so i'd have to watch myself bombing
and then and i was the most painful
psychologically thing i've ever done but
that so i would take that data every
time i did it i'd put it in a sheet i'd
write down the punch down the punch
lines i would do the conditional
formatting and i have to say i i ramped
very quickly because of that
quantification it was a ruthless way of
distilling my comedy into what works and
it and it cut my time in half
wow
that i mean yeah that's really smart
that's a really good idea yeah to me i'm
a results-oriented person i mean when my
friends would make fun of me i would say
okay i know it's crazy and i know other
stand-up comics don't do this but
it's working
yeah it's almost crazy not to do that
that's what i thought that's what i
thought but yeah i mean when when you
watch my comedy special i can hold up a
spreadsheet right next to it uh there's
that punchline yep that's a level three
laugh i knew it would be because it
always is i know this one's a shorter
laugh but we have a bunch of level two
laughs in a row here it works oh that's
so funny
okay so
how old are your kids now like how old
is your youngest so my oldest is now 17
and my youngest is eight
so okay yeah so the and these are really
fun ages okay so i have a theory that
every mom has a a childhood phase that
she kind of specializes in and then a
childhood phase that she has has no
natural skills for um i don't know
anything about babies and toddlers
nothing like i having six babies in
eight years only taught me that i i
don't know about babies i'm they're
they're just so confusing to me they're
so cute i love them but i'm i am
overwhelmed and confused by babies um
but i am really enjoying the teen years
the tween and teen ages that is more for
me like wrestling with really deep heavy
difficult subjects i could i'll stay up
with a kid till 4am talking about that
but when they're a toddler like
screaming for 15 minutes because you
looked at their cracker that that's what
i'm like i'm out i don't know what to do
with this like sylvia someone get me a
nanny i need downton abbey life where i
need to ring the bell like where's the
downstairs staff coming to help me with
this like i i can't i just can't so yeah
so i'm i'm really enjoying these ages
that's nice did you have help when kids
were really little like did you have
family or anything not as much when they
were little but i do now
and um and i will be transparent about
the fact that it is a big stretch on my
budget that i do have a nanny and um and
it's when we didn't set out to hire a
nanny but she had been babysitting for
us casually and she was such a good fit
i mean our house is it's a little bit
different i have had babysitters one in
particular she walked out in the middle
of her shift and quit and discussed
because she was so disgusted with how i
ran my house so wow yeah so at that time
i let my kids jump on the couch because
it was if they didn't have shoes on
because we were stuck inside a lot i
live in austin texas it gets very hot in
the summer it's it was too difficult to
take all those little kids somewhere and
so and the couch was very old we needed
to replace it anyway and so like my
three-year-old had a bottle which she
was horrified that i still let my
three-year-old drink from a bottle
they're all jumping on the couch and she
was like i'm i cannot like i cannot do
this so when we finally found someone
who was a good fit for our family she
rich she reached this tipping point
where she was like okay i need i need a
full-time job or i have to go somewhere
else we were like we can't lose you so
um so we have stayed in i live in a
small house 1900 square feet three
bedrooms with all eight of us in there
and that was a choice we made to stay
in that house we got it really cheap
it's a not an expensive house and then
that freed up some budget to have help
and i really evangelize for that to
women to have to consider that as a
lifestyle choice if you're able to
upgrade your lifestyle financially just
consider it's not the right choice for
everyone but consider instead of
upgrading the house or the car or
whatever upgrade your help get yourself
a nanny like i i am a big big believer
that women were meant to have help i
mean i'm not just a believer this is a
fact that throughout all of human
history women raise children in villages
women have never done this alone they've
never done it alone and i i studied
anthropology in college and if you look
at any traditional society on any place
any time in human history like 100 years
ago or before
you know you could let your kids run
around outside or even back further when
people lived in tribes you know your
kids would run around with the other
kids of the tribes i mean speaking of
the time we spend with our kids
when you look at
human evolution and tribal life women
did not see their kids that much during
the day because the kids were running
around with their older teen siblings
and women were with their babies and
maybe their toddlers but even then they
would have like a grandmother to to help
with the babies so anyway um i am a big
believer
that having help should we should
redefine it in our mind not as a luxury
but as a necessity i think it should
come right after the the electricity
bill it there are times when you can't
afford it but
if you can't afford it you should not
see it as a luxury you should see it as
a necessity yeah so part of the reason i
wanted to have you on was to talk about
that because i think like um i think
part of the reason
people aren't having as many kids
is because the idea of raising a kid
like by yourself with your partner
is extremely overwhelming and scary and
it's no wonder because people didn't
used to do that like they'd have a whole
bunch of siblings they'd all have kids i
know that in tribes there would be
people too
kind of like what we do now but people
who took care of a whole bunch of kids
and other people who went to do
different
like parts of being in a tribe berry
picking whatever different jobs right
and so it wasn't the same as what we
have now and i think that's something
women should really know about because
women are putting off
just in general putting off having kids
for so long that they have trouble
having kids
and then people don't really talk about
that and you end up with people who
can't have kids and then that's
heartbreaking for a lot of people right
and so it's just the whole
like the whole story around how to have
kids at the moment is a bit skewed oh
it's it you you nailed it and it makes
me so sad that so many women fear having
kids because they think
for what you just said but then also
they think well i wouldn't be good at it
because the quote unquote right way to
have kids is to focus on the kids for 80
90
of your waking hours to have no thoughts
or passions outside of what's going on
with the kids and so many women that
understandably think
yeah i don't think i can sign up for
that like i would be a terrible mom
because i could not sign up for that and
what i want to shout from the rooftops
is like yeah no kidding like very few
people can do that there's some women
they have a real talent for working with
young children okay they can do it the
vast majority of us can't do that
because that's not how humans have
evolved like women never did this they
didn't see their kids that much even
more recently in human history my
grandfather was a kid in like the the 19
teens and 20s and he said his mother did
not see them because they lived on a
farm so they would go run out they'd get
their guns and they'd you know hunt food
to have for dinner they would go fishing
literally she did not see them during
the day she would ring the bell and they
would come home and so yeah for for
women who feel like yeah i'd lose my
mind i just couldn't i couldn't be that
perfect mom from 7am to 11 p.m every day
it's like yeah no none of us could and
this is a totally insane expectation
that has been put on you and is by the
way historically unprecedented
yes thank you i'm very passionate i'm
very passionate about this really that
would have really helped me i think
uh
before i had scarlet and for the first
year when i was like i can't i was like
i can remember being like at home all
the time being like
and it's different when kids are like
really little like for the first you
know three to six months you're like
there's a child attached to you yeah
yeah but i can remember being like
i don't think i can do this like and
then i was like am i just a bad person
like why is it that i'm like i want to
do stuff i want to do work like
what's wrong with me kind of thing and
it wasn't until i messed it i i think i
called my aunt because i've got an aunt
and she had a nanny when her kids were
little
not super little but little and she's
like a head nurse so she was working all
the time and i called her and was like
what do i do and she was like
you'd like you sound like you might need
help and
her experience was when she went back to
work it was hard but she talked to her
kids when they're older and like my
cousins are all you know doctors or some
something like that and and they were
like yeah we like we didn't care
like if you're happy we're happy yeah
it's much better than
you know dampening down some part of you
that wants to do things and being resent
like
god forbid becoming resentful or
becoming resentful at your kids which
would be even worse
so something to avoid oh yeah well i i
went to so many play dates when my kids
were young
which are they're always so awkward i
mean that really emphasizes how much we
don't have community that it's like all
these women who have nothing in common
with each other and you're trying to
make conversation and and like they get
a bad i've heard people sort of you know
be like my like moms are uninteresting
because play dates suck so much and i
think it's not that it's that we have
nothing in common yeah nothing inc
and as i'm pretty introverted and so
honestly
yeah oh yeah
oh
is being left alone in silent rooms
maybe you're disagreeable
but disagreeable but not yeah we're
doing i'm sending you my dad's
personality test out okay i need to do
there is no way you really are 99th
percentile extrovert you're like on the
couch yelling and the internet would not
do that there's no way introverts are
very we're very passionate about all
these thoughts that we have up in our
heads no oh but well this is an example
disagreement to me it seems extroverted
women would like things like play dates
it's agreeable women oh yeah
feisty scottish ancestry like that yeah
that's why you're like funny too because
yeah i think generally speaking
comedians in order to make fun of things
you have to be kind of disagree yeah
okay i like that i'm adopting that okay
send me your dad's brother i'm going to
do that that's funny yeah because the
people who are like they can just easily
have a conversation just
enjoy kind of those
social interactions you would think that
that's extraversion but a lot of that is
agreeableness just being like okay with
things okay just being like you this is
like this is boring this is yeah that's
changed my life extroverted and that
thing's boring this is a paradigm shift
that's a real paradigm shift for me that
does that's how i feel yeah it's like
i'm just i'm like well i can't be in
this situation because i don't like how
it's being run i don't like what those
people are saying you know like yeah but
but if i'm running it then i can make it
the type of event that i want you know
oh i like that so yeah okay yeah so with
these play dates i would hear
a lot of women say i mean very common in
fact that they would they didn't
mean to they didn't mean to come across
the way they did but they would say that
you know they'd say well yeah i used to
love my life i used to
have an exciting life but you know then
bobby here came along so now i'm just
being a good mom and they would say it
in front of their kids and this would
start happening when the kids were five
and six and seven years old and and then
i saw someone say it in front of their
adult child and it's interesting this
this person really struggled with
depression and just had a lot of issues
and i wondered if this contributed that
his mother would say in front of him all
the time she'd say well i yes i had
dreams of being an artist but
you know well then being a mom i mean
that you know he came along and
and i just thought having observed that
i thought
i'm not going to do that and maybe i
will err too far on the opposite
direction i mean some i will be honest
sometimes i worry do i travel too much
am i you know when it when let's say one
of my teens is having an issue i'm like
i shouldn't have done the tour if i had
been home they wouldn't be having this
issue so i'm not saying that i am
executing it perfectly but i did make a
commitment to myself early on my kids
will never hear me say
that i didn't enjoy my life
because of them i bring them with me
into the things that i do i i mean i
tell them financials i'm like hey i lost
money on this one event what do you
think i should do for i mean i bring
them into everything it because i
because i just said early on i said my
kids will never hear me say
that i didn't live my best life and it
was because of them i'm going to go live
my best life and i'll i will bring them
into it with me and we'll live our best
lives as a family but that i was in i
was like you before i had i actually
said i didn't want to have kids because
i had that mentality yeah i know isn't
that funny i mean i if you had known me
up to my mid-20s i was like i'm never
having kids never having kids i don't
have the right temperament i can't just
literally yeah yeah yeah we should do
that we should do that changing my life
here yeah i think that's like a big
difference between the women who are
like okay with
like you said being at home all the time
and doing like glitter crafts and things
is like
i i like i die with those kind of things
yeah like a piece of music you know my
brain like it physically i feel like
physical pain in my brain when i tried
to do and and i admire a lot of my
friends can do that i admire them i'm
not being dismissive of doing glitter
crafts i wonder if she's incredible
yeah like do you think they're more
agreeable the people who like doing that
because if i think i know like no i want
to do that this is what i want to do i
want to go like do
tea parties and like this is what i want
to do and i'm like
i i think i can't get a single exception
you're right everyone i know who's
really skilled at domestic
anything
especially things like crafting and
activities yeah they all
you're right they all have that
agreeable that isn't such an interesting
thing or that is more typical with women
like if you look at the average right
women are more agreeable than men but
then you have outliers right
disagreeable yeah disagreeable women or
something or agreeable men it happens
but on average yeah that and that
resonate my husband has said to he's
like i mean he's very compliment he's
very supportive of me but he's like wow
a lot of opinions coming from this area
of the house
all the time you know just like i'm
constantly talking smack about
which is
very you know disagreeable yeah yeah
he's like can you go five minutes
without talking smack like at one point
i was really really sick i mean so
worried that he was about to take me to
the hospital but i'm still sitting there
talking about like the temperature in
the house is wrong and i don't like this
jacket and this blanket stupid and he's
like do you ever stop i mean like
probably your last words are going to be
talking smack about something oh that's
funny
this episode was brought to you by
nordpass i run my dad's company luminate
he named that
so do what you will with that i like it
i think it's cool which deals with
online products marketing brands etc we
have so many passwords and email
addresses it's insane nordpass can
simplify businesses or just your
personal life if you don't have a
password keeper you're doing life wrong
i don't know how people survive without
something like nordpass also security
breaches at giant platforms can
compromise your personal data credit
card information billing addresses etc
nordpass isn't just a password manager
it's an essential cyber security tool
developed by the experts at nordvpn
for example you can use it to secure
notes keep your secrets in there and to
keep track of your password health or
security breaches which are happening
more and more often you'll never waste
time racking your brain over a password
again because nordpass can sync your
data across up to six devices so that
you'll always log in within seconds
those are just some of the features
nordpass is a game changer it's that
simple and my listeners can take
advantage of their huge new offer right
now get 50 off nordpass premium plus one
month free
over at nordpass.com
tmpp
or just use the code tmpp the acronym
for this podcast at checkout all with a
30-day money-back guarantee that's
nordpass.com tmpp
code
tmpp
enjoy the rest of the episode
okay i saw another thing on your
instagram story you said when you first
started doing the tours because you
didn't have an agent you were booking
all these yourself yeah and i think you
underplayed how difficult that is
because when dad first started touring
he was just so this is when scarlet was
six months old and i just started
working for my dad i didn't realize you
had a little one at that time yeah yeah
and so i was at home and he's like i was
like he needs some help because my mom
was doing all his booking or his
scheduling yeah and she was so totally
overwhelmed and they had to just kind of
decide
like who he would talk to yeah and i was
like some of these you know
if he's gonna spend an hour talking to
someone he should talk to someone who
has more of a youtube following than
someone who was 10 followers right it's
like so i started being like okay i'll
just do that so because i can see who he
should talk to and then he he just like
piled on the work because there was so
much of it and part of it was oh i made
a list of like he had 30
venues
and he was like i've emailed them all so
he'd email them all and he's like can
you just follow up and book them and i
called i called the orpheum in l.a
the orpheum in la and i was like hey
like i'm just looking to book a show for
my dad and they're like i'm dying who's
your promoter
you're like did you say what's the
promoter yeah i didn't know either i was
like i we don't have a promoter i'm
sorry i don't know and i was like like
i'm full i just said like i don't know
what a promoter is yeah is that someone
who puts flyers out yeah like they they
put them on the walls and they say
what's a promoter yeah and then the
other person she's just like
like you're just here just like they
probably literally nobody calls the
orpheum and is like can i just uh hey my
dad's anyway it gets it gets better so i
was like no so then i was mad about it
because i was getting she's just talking
down and i was like you don't understand
like i think he could he could sell a
show like
who is this person
yeah and so then she sent me over a list
and it was like i think it was 30k to
book the orpheum yeah and it was like
you have to book a bunch of these
parking spots and pay for ushers and
things and i was like do you have to get
insurance i didn't know about that
insurance
yeah i can remember being like well do
we we don't need all these parking spots
and we don't need that much security and
they're like no it comes with the show
and i was just like oh okay anyway
we met we managed to do it and he sold
out the orpheum but that was
that that's so satisfying too that like
they because it's hard to sell out
events even even for big names and
venues that was that a satisfying moment
where you oh
i told you so yeah they were they were
surprised but it was great yeah and they
were like who's your dad and i was like
oh he's a professor and they're like a
professor of the year we don't have a
lot of professors coming through here
wow yeah what's your writer i was like
yeah what's a writer i literally had to
google what is a writer okay and and we
tried to play it cool like
yes uh my my people have my writer uh i
will get back
like what is a i copied and pasted a
writer template that i found on the
internet that had it had all these
lighting requirements in it and it's
like we need the xyz gel filter and then
i get there and it was for a broadway
show and i'm like what is going on with
these light it was like you know like
i'm gonna be little orphan annie like
doing
i was like okay so none of this is going
to work they're like but it's in your
writer i'm like okay yeah so tear that
up and uh just give me a spot copy and
paste it obviously yeah yeah right and
and then with the entrance i had to sign
something you probably did too because
so i didn't know i had to get event
insurance and i had to sign stuff that
said like there will be no flame
throwing at my event initial here there
will be no tractor pulls but my initial
there will be no mechanical bull riding
and then i was like you're like
yeah i mean actually i'm not sure if i
can commit to that it just gave me a
bunch of ideas like it sounds like a lot
of fun to do tractor pulls drag racing
mechanical bull riding and flame
throwing i think that would be an
incredible your dad might want to
consider it with this tour he's doing
the bowl for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah we
could do that
yeah i can just leave it there i'm doing
the opening yeah yeah and well or maybe
it could be like a um a darwinian like
only the fittest fans get into this
event like you have to last eight
seconds
on the mechanical bull in order to get
in even if you've already paid like we
just want to make sure that we have the
hardiest fans in attendance he's pretty
busy too i could pull that off probably
without anybody noticing for like a
number of shows
yeah
and you're like wait what is
where is everyone yeah yeah i told them
they had to write and then people are
coming in with like bandages and eye
patches
i think it's a vision it gives me good
good ideas yeah yeah anyway i got
started on that that tangent because you
said at the beginning before you were
more set up or had an agent or anything
you had your kids coming to help you
with shows yes and uh because i could
share a hotel room with my kids and so
just getting a plane ticket for some of
the kids and we homeschooled at the time
so i was homeschooling in addition to
booking this this big tour but that did
help because i was doing weeknight shows
the kids could come with me i couldn't
afford to take all six and so we we laid
out the tour schedule and i let them
choose in groups of twos which ones they
would go to
and that's so fun yeah i know
i know and we're doing it i think with
the next tour too i think there i think
we'll do the same thing i'll take them
out of school which i'm sure the schools
will really appreciate but uh but yeah
it it was it was really cool and what's
funny is that it never occurred to the
theaters that i was not traveling with
staff and so i had a couple incidents
where like the sound guys or the light
guys would say something they'd be like
yeah i heard the the manager said that
the uh this headliner is you know she
can get a little testy sometimes like
with the theater we had a lot of issues
with and i was like oh that's me
actually because they saw me showing up
to do light check they had no idea i was
the headliner but then they'd say okay
like well where's your staff we need
your we need your tour manager to kind
of talk to the ushers and i would just
bring out my 12 year old daughter
and we'd have home school stuff like um
i actually had they got a good education
but i i literally i gave them a
homeschool project i had them watch
video of my set and make notes and you
know what's interesting is they gave me
great feedback because if you have ever
tried to make your own tween and teen
children laugh
especially the mom like no tween and
teen kids ever think their mom is funny
so when they would say this section is
actually this is actually really good we
think it's really funny sure enough that
would kill in the clubs because you can
if you can make your kids laugh you can
make anyone laugh
so um so yeah so they were actually a
really critical part of the tour so much
so i'm it would have been very hard to
do it without them
wow yeah because i wasn't making quite
enough money that i could like hire
staff members you know i need i needed
everything to go back in my pocket that
i made from ticket sales wow
huh so why do you think
you had
like the self-confidence i guess
to
book shows and assume that you'd sell
out like is that a personality thing is
that how you were raised or something
you learned so it's not how i was raised
both of my parents were very very risk
averse people like you you get your nine
to five and you you know you're
respectful of the boss man to try to
keep your boss and you to try to keep
your job so no i come from very very
risk averse that's interesting yeah um
so i i think that um it might be part of
i i've often thought i'd probably have
undiagnosed uh adhd because i am um i'm
a very like thrill-seeking person i i
need life to be interesting and actually
one way so
one way in which my dad was not risk
averse is he was a green beret uh during
the vietnam era and he did halo and
demolitions training so he taught people
how to blow things up and how to jump
out of airplanes at night
um at high altitudes because that's how
they would evade radar that the viet
cong or whoever they were trying to
avoid would not guess that they were
dropping parachute people because they
were way way high
so my and it would always be at night so
that you wouldn't be seen and that was
my dad's specialty and so i've often
thought that maybe i did get that gene
for yeah this is my version of jumping
out of airplanes at night is putting an
entire theater tour on my credit card
and hoping it works out that's kind of
the same thing so i guess maybe i did
have that little element of thrill
seeking from my dad but you know i am
one of those people i just
i don't know if this is a good trait or
a bad trait but
i cannot have life be boring like i
cannot be bored and so i'm constantly
kind of escalating and
doing crazy things and my husband is the
same way we're we're a good match in
that sense um he is also he just can't
be bored he likes to try different
things and so we um we're kind of a bad
influence on each other in any crazy
idea i have ever had he's always like
yeah yeah you should do it yeah
absolutely yeah go for it and uh so yeah
if i had a different spouse that it
might have played out differently but he
is also
likes to keep life interesting so he
he's been along for the ride for all of
this
that's so fun it's it really is and
that's part of my
mission i have this bigger mission
um
with comedy and with everything i do
when i think back to the person i was
when i thought i didn't want to have
kids it was all based on this
misunderstanding it was based on this
false idea that you have to be boring
especially as a woman if you're going to
be the ones having the kids and doing it
right
then you had just better get ready to be
boring for like two decades out of your
life
and i can't sign up for that i don't
like i'll die i mean that my my brain
will melt i just
maybe this is even a bad thing maybe
it's something i need to go to therapy
for but it is what it is
i can't have a boring life and
i almost missed out on
this incredible life like i'm so
grateful for my kids for my family i
love my life
so much i i can't even put it into words
and to think that i almost missed out on
it based on the misunderstanding that
you have to be boring if you're a mother
i swear my life's work like if i
convince one person that you can be
interesting and you can have kids even a
lot of kids if that's the right path for
you
then i will feel like
everything i have done
is worth it every sacrifice every
rejection every difficult thing i've
gone through in my career
it is worth it if i put forth into the
world
a new
model of what motherhood can look like
i'm going to use that as the trailer for
the episode nice that was really good
nice yeah i really i really appreciate
that i really appreciate that
that's very cool i really feel like
that's if there's like you know all
these motivational people they always
say find your why what is your why i'm
crystal clear on my why it's it's bigger
than comedy itself yeah i want to do
great comedy of course i want to be
considered a top-notch you know
hilarious comedian but
i'm not just here to make silly jokes
you know like if you if you see my
comedy in the even the sketches i do on
instagram they're not all
silly yeah i i have a very serious
streak and i i'm not here to just
you know
make silly jokes about silly things i'm
i'm here
to have an impact on the world i
wouldn't be doing this if i it's hard i
mean this you know booking tours i mean
this work that we do it's very hard it
involves a lot of rejection it involves
a lot of frustration it involves haters
you know people in your dms and in your
comments saying nasty things i wouldn't
do this
if if i didn't have a bigger mission and
it's it's to put forth a different
way of existing as a woman and as a
mother
that's fantastic
okay i wanted to talk that's great
that's exactly why i wanted to have you
on it's like i think that could be
helpful for like a lot of people to hear
and i don't think just
women i think it's helpful for men to
hear too because depending on how you
were brought up then you view what
parenthood should be like completely
like differently right some people are
like oh no my parents were at work all
the time some parents were at home some
people had stay-at-home moms some people
didn't so i think it's really good for
everybody to hear that you can do what
you want and you can make it work you
don't have to do things a certain way as
long as you're as long as it feels right
to you right like obviously
you don't neglect your child
but being at home and doing glitter
paint for six hours a day isn't
necessarily what makes you a good mom it
could be whatever makes you the happiest
so you cannot be resentful around your
kid yes right and raise them properly so
that they don't have a resentful parent
because like you said those are you see
that at restaurants sometimes too when
there's a kid and they're like freaking
out i went out for dinner with my mom
and my dad and scarlett in the summer
and there was a kid next to us who was
four two like scarlett and she wasn't
being that bad but she was she could
tell that the bad she was being was
because she wanted attention yeah and
didn't have enough attention so she was
like kind of acting out and the mom was
there and she was just like
right like the whole time and ended up
apologizing profusely for her kid and
thanks and we were just like oh
yikes yeah that is not gonna go anywhere
nice in the next couple years totally
already somewhere not nice right yeah
and it's it's really about that like
connection
with your kids and the more you are
bringing energy into your life by living
a life of passion you have more energy
to share with your kids to connect with
your kids to get to know your kids so
that you don't end up in situations like
that where you kind of
block them out because you're so
depressed and overwhelmed by your
existence that you're just you don't
have the energy to sit down you might be
physically with your kids all day every
day but you you just don't have the
energy to like really connect with them
yeah
and by the way i i do think this is an
important message for men
too because i i know that for example my
dad he passed away a couple years ago
but i i saw him struggle his whole
adult life because he did have that
thrill-seeking tendency from being a
green beret but he very much felt like
he had to stay in jobs he hated because
he was a father oh that's a good
and
i've actually never spoken about this
publicly but hey this is a good time to
get this out there that i have been in
therapy about that and i
really struggled with feeling i'm an
only child um it's interesting my
husband is an only child we're both only
children but i even though i'm an only
child i i grew up
feeling like as much as my parents loved
me and they loved me a ton i mean like
great great great parents
but i did have this sense that
my dad's life would have been more
exciting to him if i hadn't been born
and i was also i was a surprise that my
parents didn't intend to have kids and
um i carried that with me my whole life
this feeling that my dad he always hated
his jobs they were constantly
i mean my my association my association
with my father in work was
misery stress anxiety um i i don't think
i ever saw him happy in his work but the
me the narrative was like well i'm a dad
so i don't i don't get to like follow my
dreams or do interesting things i
haven't even thought about
i haven't even thought that that would
hit men too oh yeah
how many men
are living existences they hate
because they feel like
i have to or it pays slightly better you
have to earn more money
yeah and they think the right way to be
a dad is to make sure that every kid has
a car when they're 16 you can give them
a full ride to college they have brand
name clothes
and
so many men you know they wake up one
day and they're 50 or they're 60 and
they're like
well there there went my life you know
there went so many years out of my life
and like
i
don't feel good about a lot of what i've
done like i've hated my job i've been a
wage slave and so part of my message
even though i mostly speak to women is
when when you have this kind of life
where you see
where you say that we will live an
exciting life like we're not going to be
boring you can partner with your family
and with your spouse and say hey you
know what let's actually not upgrade the
house even though it would be great to
have more room so that dad can quit this
job he hates you know what let's
downgrade the house like let's we'll
have three kids in a bedroom throw some
bunk beds in there you know i know all
these big families like four kids in a
small room that is nothing like they're
fine with that let's let's downgrade
like let's live a more free life so that
dad can start that business that he
always dreamed about doing and yes it
might be a financial disaster but let's
be with dad as he takes a shot on that
and
so so men are are really in need of that
message of freedom as well and and i
think i i benefited from my husband's
experience that uh he was raised by a
single mother his father was just not
part of his life his mom i mean she
hardly made any money they were so poor
that there were times when she didn't
know what how she would get dinner i
mean they like no money poor
and um
and so she wasn't able to pay for him to
go to college but you know he ended up
going to yale and having you know doing
very very well academically
um but his mom couldn't help him with
any of it she was like you're on your
own for college you're on your own for
buying clothes you have to get a job and
and it was fine and so my husband never
walked in with that expectation
that the only way to be a good parent is
to give your kids a high upper middle
class life because he was like my life
was great and i mean it was hard in a
lot of ways but he was like i my mom
couldn't pay for anything for me and all
that mattered to me as a kid is that i
had her love and i had her support and
that i was her priority in life and so
um
so
you know and i try to support my husband
in that to not have him feel like he has
to be stuck in in jobs that he hates um
just so that we can live a certain
lifestyle um i'm really glad we covered
that maybe that's partly what's
contributing that's got to be because
like i know i grew up in a
downtown toronto so people are pretty
liberal and nobody has kids still like
the average age of kids i don't know
maybe 33 or 34 like it's it's much later
and a lot of
my friends who were guys were like
you know you get you you get married and
have a kid and your life's over right
like literally your life is over right
right and when i had scarlet and was
pregnant i can remember some of my
friends being like you do this your life
is over yeah right yep and i'm like
that's terrifying
i don't think you're right but that's
really scary
so no i'm glad we we covered this
because i'm sure men are worried about
that too and i think my dad's got a rule
and it was in his first book i think
which is don't let your kids do anything
that makes you hate them i remember that
i read that and i was like man that's
that's solid that's really good yeah and
one of the most like insidious types i
think of hate for kids is when
it's not as outward it's like oh well
till this guy came along life was pretty
good but i love him that was that was my
dad's like and he did like he was my
biggest fan my biggest supporter but
there was this wee
constant sort of background static of
but his life was more exciting before i
came out so it's not in his life and
tricky yeah when i came along i think
that could also go badly like if you're
in
a relationship that's not great you
could also be like well it's not the
kid's fault it's this other person's
fault right so then that could happen
right so it's just better to try and be
aware of all those
potential areas of resentment and
whatever you do
even if it feels like
it's i guess selfish then maybe it's
something to try out so that you don't
have to present for
usually if it avoids resentment i don't
think it's selfish right because being
resentful makes everyone miserable
totally well so this actually just
crystallized for me in in this moment
that i i think a very important dynamic
with this whole women finding freedom
when they have kids is
this it's funny to you saying that just
made me realize i think a dynamic that
can come up is if your husband hates his
job but he is slogging it out every day
to so that you can stay home with the
kids or even if you don't stay home if
just you know you're trying to do the
right thing as a mom you feel all the
more pressure because if your husband is
out there like he hates what he's doing
he's not happy ever during the day he's
you know coming home just frazzled and
frustrated every single night you you
feel guilty being like well who am i i i
think subconsciously almost you're like
i should be miserable yeah you know i
could you know get this book deal i
could do this writing project while i'm
staying home with the kids but i'd
better be doing things that make me
miserable because how unfair would that
be if i'm like following my passions and
living my best life while my husband is
punching the clock in a job that he
despises and i i just now kind of
remembered that this was something that
my husband and i had to go through when
things were taking off for me with
writing and i was really in the zone and
and using that you know blue flame
he hated his job and there was this
unspoken tension of like okay
we need to even this out a little bit i
shouldn't have all the joy you know yeah
and so that was when we started talking
about doing the tour finding better ways
to monetize my career i said look i it's
going to take me a few months to
monetize this to the point that you
might be able to scale back the amount
of work that you're doing so that you
can go you know he loves sailing you
know explore that passion a little bit
more and it did i mean it took about a
year before i could shift things with my
income so that i could monetize this
work that i was doing
but then it became this really beautiful
thing where we were partnering together
financially yeah where neither one of us
had to live a life that we hated where
each one of us could wake up and say wow
i'm really looking forward to the state
like i have things i'm passionate about
this is great and it again it was a very
intentional process and it took a long
time of us working together to figure
out how to make that work for both of us
but it is a really beautiful thing when
you can hook that up
okay let's get into that a tiny bit so
it's like negotiating yeah i think if
yeah if i'm correct we'll see what
happens with your test but if you are
disagreeable which i think you i think i
am yeah i want to do the test though i i
think that makes because i scored like a
high on compassion agreeableness splits
into
compassion and politeness okay so i
scored like 88 on compassion and like
zero on politeness like
like rock bottom but then it makes it
averages me to like kind of like low
average for agreeableness because they
combine
but i think being lower in politeness
makes it easier to negotiate
because you're less likely to be at
least for me i'm less likely to be
concerned about not saying something
because i'll hurt somebody's feelings
yeah right it'll be like well no it
actually
it's something we need to talk about so
that they'll be your feelings hurt in
the future right even if it's kind of
uncomfortable at the moment that's such
a good skill and i probably don't get
that uncomfortable so that also helps
with negotiating because yeah this isn't
that bad
that's a great skill i'm not as good at
that i i am i guess with people i know
but that that is hard for me
um
with my you know what helped with the
conversations i had with my husband is
that we started with the goal we started
by saying let's dream of a life where we
are both
doing things that we're passionate about
we we both have elements of you know we
we just love what we're into and we can
somehow pay the bills let's start with
that vision in mind so it felt
very collaborative that we were heading
out on this crazy venture together
and that definitely helped those
conversations have
just
have a little bit more smoothness you
know to them that it wasn't
it wasn't uh me versus him it wasn't us
versus them it was
how can we both sacrifice and work
towards this vision and that helped a
lot
that's a good idea
okay so a few more questions i think
another kid question how are you
teaching them
to be like do you think you going on
teacher on tour helps them become more
self-confident like they are they
concerned about are they confident
children especially with homeschooling
yeah do you think they'd be concerned
with performing in front of other people
oh that's an interesting question um
actually wait let me say one i just
remembered something i meant to say on
the previous subject that i think is
really important for women who are
interested in that the key thing that
made that work with me and my husband is
i had to let go of imposter syndrome um
when women
start to develop their passions like
figure out what what might i like to do
while i'm raising these kids
there is a tendency to have imposter
syndrome where you don't take it
seriously you know maybe you're doing
writing but you won't call yourself a
writer in order to have these
conversations with my husband where it's
like okay how can we have you work less
how can i help you with that well i had
to start to take myself seriously in my
work and say you know what i'm i'm okay
at this i'm pretty good at this i might
be able to make money and so a key
element for women who are listening to
us and thinking about this you've got to
let go of imposter syndrome and own your
gifts and own your talents and be
willing to go for it because then that
can help you monetize
whatever your passion is which matters
if you're if you need to support a
husband who's like trying to quit a job
he hates so that letting go of imposter
syndrome is is really important um so
for my kids
i i think they are very confident yes
they all seem i mean these kids are not
that susceptible to peer pressure i mean
some of the like they just
they just don't
they don't seem to care that much what
their what their peers uh i mean they're
they're um i mean they have friends i
don't mean to say they don't they don't
care about their peers at all but um
they do seem to be very confident now i
don't know how they would feel about
speaking on
a stage but
they have certainly grown up in a house
where
it is normalized to bet on yourself
that they have they've seen
they've seen no contrary examples to
that it is a bet on yourself household
and so
they don't know anything different than
that and and four of my six kids are
girls
i have four daughters and so i love it
that they're growing up um in a culture
of freedom to be yourself and
encouragement to believe in yourself and
to bet on yourself yeah actually and i
think that's one of the other reasons
for women
and men for that matter but to pursue
what they want because it would teach
your kid that they have the ability to
pursue what they want right which is
what you're trying to teach them anyway
so if they grow up in a household and
they see one of their parents stifled by
something and miserable then they're
just going to learn the wrong thing
about what they're capable of right so
that's that's actually a less you know
selfish reason to go pursue something
would be to teach your kids that they
can
when you discover who you really are
as a parent and you go for it and you be
that person unapologetically even if you
know what if your
craft woman and you're like michaela jen
i'm glitter craft woman i we do glitter
clap crafts five hours a day every day
and i love it and like screw anyone who
doesn't like this whatever whoever it is
you are when you discover that and you
go for it you are implicitly giving your
children permission
to be whoever they are yeah you have
normalized being your authentic self in
your house and i think that that is a
real gift for kids
that's great
yeah i like that a lot
i had one more comment what was the
topic you you came back to it oh i said
that uh letting go of imposter syndrome
okay yeah that's what yeah i wanted to
address that and then it completely left
my head i think i've had
i think everybody who gets into
something new has that issue
but i'm surprised you have that you you
come across as very confident i well i
am confident but
so i don't know if it's not a confident
problem i think it's just under play
undervaluing maybe some of what i do and
part of it's from having dad get as
famous as he's gotten yeah
but i have this to be hard
well i've gotten like i've had actual
hard things happen so it's not that hard
but
uh not compared to like hard and painful
right i'm like uh yeah it's not that
hard but um i have noticed like some of
the
nah i just i'll figure it out eventually
i think i have had that problem though i
don't know if it's from being
like female or from my dad or
being a mom
i'm not sure yeah something to think
about though i had that problem with the
i told you i'm doing a show at zany's
tomorrow yes
yeah and i was like oh cool like i have
a show but i have like i've been doing
so much work for my dad with his brand
that was like i didn't put tick like i
didn't advertise it for like a long time
like it was on sale my like agent is
messaging me is like can you tell people
and i was like oh yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah it's like i don't know
self-sabotage or something no it's just
well that's the thing is
there is no
tidy way
to live an interesting life interesting
lives are messy by definition and i
think sometimes we
we resist living an interesting life
because we're afraid of mess but that's
how it is like when your father has this
super interesting career yeah like of
course you want to be part of that who
wouldn't that's amazing and um and
you're a mom and you've got stuff going
on with your daughter and you've got
your own podcast you've got your own
media empire going
things are going to slip it's messy yeah
you know i mean with my own toy i've had
like i'm about to go out on tour very
soon and um i've had things slip and i
beat myself up about it but you have to
keep coming back to
um an interesting life is is always
a messy
life you know if maybe you would have
been perfectly on top of ticket sales if
you weren't doing all this stuff with
your dad but like who wants that yeah
yeah exactly yeah
okay jen
if people don't follow you online where
should they go and is there a place they
can go to buy tickets yes
jfcomedytour.com
you're welcome for not making anyone
spell full weiler i just did jf
comedy.com uh yeah i'm going to let me
see if i can get the cities off the top
of my head topeka dallas san antonio
boston new york city
some odc
uh fort lauderdale orlando and atlanta
to start we will add cities after that
jfcomedytour.com
and this is my first big theater tour
with my new fancy agents and my new
fancy managers so not not just cold
calling theaters with a credit card
anymore so we're all the petersons and
the full bothers we're all taking it to
the next level and um yeah i always try
to make my show something you can bring
anyone like my comedy's good but i keep
it clean enough that you're not your
neighbor is not going to be horrified by
anything i say i'm not doing politics
and stuff like that because um women
need community and i want
my shows
to be something where everyone feels
welcome so that we can start building
community by having a chance to just get
dressed up have a night out have a
dinner so i really encourage people to
come out even if they're just
discovering me for the first time
thank you very much for coming on that
was great what a joy this is amazing
[Music]
you